>> Sean: THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
JEFF SESSIONS MADE A MAJOR
ANNOUNCEMENT YESTERDAY RIGHT
HERE ON THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
HE TOLD US THAT THEY WILL BE
INVESTIGATING THE NINE ABUSES
COMMITTED BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
FINALLY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO INVESTIGATE
THE FACT THAT THE FCI USE THE
DOSSIER TO GET A WIRETAP AGAINST
TRUMP ASSOCIATES AND THEY DID
NOT TELL THE FISA COURT THAT THE
DEMOCRATS PAID FOR THAT DOSSIER?
>> LET ME TELL YOU.
EVERY FISA WARRANT BASED ON
FACTS SUBMITTED TO THAT HAS TO
BE ACCURATE.
THAT WILL BE INVESTIGATED AND
LOOKED AT, AND WE ARE NOT GOING
TO PARTICIPATE AS A DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND PROVIDING
ANYTHING LESS THAN THE PROPER
DISCLOSURE TO    BEFORE THE ISSU
DISCLOSURE TO    BEFORE THE ISSE
DISCLOSURE TO    BEFORE THE ISSA
FISA WARRANT.
>> Sean: NOW WITH REACTION
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR BYRON YORK
AND SEBASTIAN GORKA.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
WE LEARN FIRST AND BROKER HERE
ON THOSE PROGRAMS THAT JEFF
SESSIONS NEVER RECUSED HIMSELF
FROM THE URANIUM ONE ISSUE.
A FEW WEEKS BACK, LO AND BEHOLD,
WE HAD ANOTHER INDICTMENT.
EVERYONE THOUGHT THAT WAS A DEAD
ISSUE.
I THINK HILLARY TALKING POINT IS
THAT WAS WRONG.
THAT'S ONGOING.
WHAT I'M HEARING IS THAT IF YOU
LIE TO A FISA JUDGE, YOU
WITHHOLD INFORMATION, A FOOTNOTE
THAT SAYS IT MIGHT HAVE SOME
POLITICAL CONNECTIONS IS NOT
THAT THE OTHER CANDIDATE PAID
FOR THESE LIES.
I TOOK THAT TO BE A VERY SERIOUS
SHOT ACROSS THE BOW.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
EVERYBODY'S TALKING ABOUT THE 13
INDICTMENTS.
BYRON JUST WROTE A VERY GOOD
PIECE ABOUT IT, BUT THE REAL
STORY THAT WE HAVE TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF ARE THE LEAKS OUT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THERE ARE 27 REFERRALS.
THE DOJ ARE LOOKING INTO THE
LEAKS, INCLUDING THE LEAKS
BETWEEN MIKE FLYNN AND THE
RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR.
SERIOUS NATIONAL SECURITY
INVESTIGATIONS.
URANIUM WANT ABSOLUTELY
STRATEGIC LEVEL.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE SOMETHING
LARGER THAN A SALE OF 20% OF OUR
URANIUM, WHEN WE HAVE LAWS ON
THE BOOK RIGHT NOW THAT SAY
AMERICA MUST BE A SELF-RELIANT.
WE MUST NOT IMPORT IT FROM
ANYBODY.
HILLARY CLINTON APPROVED THE
SALE OF URANIUM WHILE HER
HUSBAND GOT HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS SPEAKING FEE.
IT'S JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG.
THESE THINGS TAKE TIME.
REST ASSURED, JUSTICE WILL BE
DONE.
>> Sean: BYRON, YOU HAD A
GREAT COLUMN OUT.
YOUR WEBSITE -- THAT WEBSITE IS
HORRIBLE.
I HAD TO GET YOU TO CUT AND
PASTE IT TO SEND IT TO ME.
EVERY TIME I CLICK ON IT, THAT
SMOKING THING COMES UP AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
IT DRIVES ME NUTS.
I WANT YOU TO GO THROUGH THIS.
IF YOU REALLY LOOK AT THE
MUELLER INDICTMENT THE WAY YOU
ARE LOOKING AT IT, IT'S NOT WHAT
PEOPLE THINK.
>> I THINK YOU NEED TO LOOK AT
THIS INDICTMENT IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE TESTIMONY OF FACEBOOK
AND OTHER SOCIAL MEDIA
EXECUTIVES ON CAPITOL HILL A FEW
MONTHS AGO.
THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF THAT THEY
TALKED ABOUT THAT WAS NOT IN THE
INDICTMENT.
WHAT THEY TALK ABOUT THE SUM OF
THE SCALE OF THIS RUSSIAN
OPERATION.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE RUSSIAN
SPEND ABOUT $100,000 ON FACEBOOK
AND SPIRIT THAT COMPARES TO
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON AND
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANT
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANU
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANP
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANC
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANM
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANA
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANG
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANN
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANS
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANE
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANT
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANO
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANN
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANF
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANC
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANB
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANO
$81 MILLION THAT THE CLINTON ANK
ADS.
THEY TALKED ABOUT HOW JUST 44%
OF THOSE AD IMPRESSIONS, WHEN
THEY ARE UP ON THE SCREEN
SOMEWHERE, 44% OF THOSE WERE
FROM BEFORE THE ELECTION.
56% WERE AFTER THE ELECTION WHEN
THE ODYSSEY HAD NO CHANCE OF
INFLUENCING THE ELECTION, AND
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THE
RUSSIAN SPENT IN SOME KEY STATES
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW IN THAT THE
INDICTMENT, TALKED ABOUT HOW THE
RUSSIANS BECAME SOPHISTICATED
AND LEARN WHAT PURPLE STATES
WERE.
THEY WERE DIRECTING THEIR
EFFORTS IN THE STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
ACCORDING TO FACEBOOK, THEY
SPENT $300.
IN MICHIGAN, THEY SPENT $823,
AND IN WISCONSIN, $1,079.
THE PROBLEM WAS, ALL BUT $54 OF
THAT WAS PUT TOWARDS THE
PRIMARY.
NOT IN THE GENERAL ELECTION.
ALL OF THAT IS TESTIMONY THAT WE
HAD FOR CONGRESS.
>> Sean: FACTS AND CONTEXT AND
TEXTURE MEAN AN AWFUL LOT.
EXCEPT IT DOESN'T FIT THE MEDIA
NARRATIVE.
THAT'S GREAT REPORTING ON YOUR
PART.
LIMIT GO BACK TO YOU, SEBASTIAN.
WHAT GOES TO THE HEART OF THIS
FOR ME.
EVERYBODY IS SO SANCTIMONIOUSLY
AND IN THEIR POMPOUS ARROGANCE
TALKS ABOUT THIS RUSSIAN
INFLUENCE.
OKAY.
WE CAN'T TALK ABOUT RUSSIAN
INFLUENCE AND IGNORE URANIUM
ONE.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT RUSSIAN
INFLUENCE AND IGNORE THE
HILLARY CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT DOSSIER.
>> HOW CAN WE IGNORE IT --
AGAIN, WE GOT TO STICK TO THE
FACTS OF THE MATTER.
THE OPPOSITION RESEARCH FOUND
THAT THEY PAID MORE THAN
$12 MILLION FOR ONE FILE WAS
USED TO ILLEGALLY OBTAIN A
SURVEILLANCE WARRANT AGAINST AN
AMERICAN NATIONAL DURING A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S THE ENORMITY.
IT MAKES WATERGATE PALE BY
COMPARISON.
IT'S A MASSIVE SCANDAL.
>> Sean: LAST WORD, BYRON.
>> I THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE
MORE AND MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
THIS.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, WE WILL SEE
HOW THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
ASKING FOR MORE INFORMATION FROM
A VARIETY OF CURRENT AND FORMER
OFFICIALS ABOUT, WHAT DO THEY
KNOW ABOUT THIS DOSSIER?
WHEN DID THEY FIRST HEAR ABOUT
IT?
WHEN DID THEY FIRST LEARNED THAT
IT WAS SUPPORTED AND BANKROLLED
BY THE HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN
AND THE DNC.
THESE ARE VERY BASIC QUESTIONS
THAT WE STILL DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWERS.
>> Sean: YOUR REPORTING HAS
STOOD VERY MUCH INDEPENDENT AND
APART FROM THE     THOSE THAT LV